The conundrum for U.S. policymakers in the
fight against ISIS is what to do about Iran
and Iran's efforts to combat the terrorist
group themselves.
On the one hand, it looks like that we would
have similar interests to Iran.
They both oppose the radical Sunni extremist
group and they also are looking to keep Iraq
as a single country.
On those two points, we agree.
ISIS should be defeated, Iraq should stay
together.
But at the same time, they have a different
vision where Iraq, Syria, Lebanon, other countries
are coming more under the Iranian sphere.
The challenge for this White House, which
it's not willing to take right now, and maybe
a President Clinton or President Trump would,
is to have a more confrontational policy towards
Iran in its activities in Iraq and Syria and
Lebanon.
We're very clear where we're not going to
allow these militia groups and other proxies
of Iran to become the dominant player in Iraq
or Syria's or Lebanon's security and political
structures.